the opening scene shows a student named
Josh ockman who is quickly walking
towards the university building on his
way he sees a mysterious figure in a
bike side mirror but it vanishes when he
takes a Second Glance although this
alarms him briefly he dismisses it and
proceeds to the library by taking an
elevator with an elderly man upon
entering the library Josh finds it
strangely dim and deserted he calls out
for his friend Douglas Ziegler whom he
was supposed to meet there but there is
no response leaving him feeling anxious
despite his unease Josh cautiously
explores the library at one point he is
startled by the same old man's sudden
appearance causing him to drop some
books from the Shelf as he picks up the
books the old man departs with his Rusty
book cart still searching for his friend
Josh Witnesses unsettling events such as
flickering tube lights books falling
from shelves and the old man's cart
moving on its own peeves is here curious
he approaches the card only to become
confronted by a terrifiers
which scares the life out of him just
then a creepy humanoid spirit with long
fingers grabs Josh's head and drains the
life force from his body Josh is [__]
dead in the next scene we are introduced
to four University friends named Isabel
Stone Tim and Maddie who are having a
few drinks in a packed bar everyone
seems to be enjoying the moment except
for Maddie who is concerned about her
computer geek boyfriend Josh because he
has been away for a week sensing her
worry Isabel suggests moving on from
Josh considering the time they spent a
part outweighs their time together
afterwards Tim who Harbors feelings for
Maddie offers to walk her home but she
kindly declines as she considers him
only a friend upon arriving back at her
apartment Maddie listens to a couple of
her voicemails one from her mother and
surprisingly the other from Josh however
the second message is empty with Josh
merely calling her name and hanging up
concerned Maddie tries calling him back
but he still does not answer the phone
that night Maddie is on to sleep so she
checks on her roommate Isabel only to
discover that she is not home it turns
out that she is sleeping with a random
guy at his place as a result many texts
Isabelle asking her to come back home
the following day after attending
college classes Maddie decides to visit
Josh's apartment to check on him once
there she knocks on the door but
receives no response from inside
eventually she finds a spare key above
the door enabling her to get in as soon
as she enters she discovers the
apartment in complete disarray with the
computer code running after a while Josh
walks out but he appears to be different
not quite himself Maddie asks where he
had been and why he hadn't been
answering the phone however instead of
answering her he rolls up an ethernet
cable and heads into a room telling her
to wait in the kitchen while waiting she
finds Josh's pet cat locked in a closet
and dying from severe malnutrition
distressed Maddie rushes to ask Josh
about what's going on but to her
complete shock he has committed the
unthinkable using the ethernet cable
dark and nerdy in the aftermath of this
traumatic event Maddie suffers mentally
so she seeks help from a psychiatrist
during one of her sessions she breaks
down feeling responsible for not being
able to prevent Josh's tragic fate
however the psychiatrist offers
reassurance telling her that it's not
her fault and that Josh may have hidden
his loneliness for a long time later
that day Maddie's friends try to console
her by sending supportive messages in a
group chat but much to their surprise
they received messages from Josh's
account asking for help the next day the
four friends meet on campus to discuss
this strange occurrence they then
speculate that Josh's computer might
still be on and a virus is causing the
messages as a result Stone decides to go
to Josh's apartment and log off the
computer after classes Stone goes to
Josh's place and explores the Eerie
house to his horror he soon sees a pale
lady emerging from the wall and
advancing towards him in a panicked
State Stone tries to hide under the bed
but the Ghostly entity reaches him and
drains his soul just like what happened
to Josh that's what you get for trying
to hide under the bed from a ghost
freaking idiot the next day Maddie calls
Stone to inquire if he managed to turn
off the computer but as expected the
possessed Stone doesn't talk much on the
phone disturbed by the situation Maddie
decides to take matters into her own
hands and heads to Josh's apartment
however she finds the place being
cleaned out and vacant by the landlady
Maddie asks about the computer and the
landlady explains that she had already
sold it because Josh hadn't paid the
rent for several months despite this
Maddie traces the computer's buyer who
name is Dex McCarthy and pays him a
visit she accuses him of using her
boyfriend's computer to send strange
messages confused Ducks shows her that
he hadn't even connected the computer
leaving Maddie bewildered as she departs
in order to figure out what she was
saying Dax later plugs in the computer
and discovers a series of peculiar
videos among them one video shows Josh
taking a gun and tragically committing
the unthinkable terrified Dex calls
Maddie and shows her the distressing
footage leaving her deeply unsettled a
few days later while at College Maddie
receives a package set by Josh two days
prior to his death inside she finds
rolls of red tape and a message from
Josh saying that these tapes keep them
out adding to the mystery and confusion
surrounding the events as days pass by
Maddie begins to experience increasingly
terrifying nightmares and visions of
horrifying Spirits she also Witnesses
disturbing scenes of people committing
the unthinkable right in front of her
these experiences lead her to believe
that something evil is pursuing her one
day she visits her psychiatrist but even
he dismisses her claims as
hallucinations trying to accept this
explanation Maddie attempts to maintain
her normal daily routine and attends
College however she notices an unusual
Trend the university is gradually
becoming emptier as students stopped
showing up one day while in the restroom
Maddie hears strange noises so she goes
to investigate suddenly she catches a
glimpse of someone peering through one
of the bathroom doors which frightens
her and she flees in panic in the next
scene Tim decides to visit Stone as he
has been unresponsive to phone calls for
several days upon entering his apartment
Tim finds him in a distressed State
tearfully saying I don't want to die but
before Tim can react stone is
mysteriously pulled in and engulfed by
the wall leaving only a dark Trace
behind this terrifies Tim so he rushes
back to his own place and frantically
covers the doors and windows using red
tape after covering everything he looks
through the door's peephole and at the
same time a humanoid figure with a large
mouth suddenly attacks him that red tape
didn't do [__] on the same night
Maddie's computer turns on by itself and
starts playing some strange videos
scared she disconnects all the computer
wires but still the printer begins
printing some images upon assembling all
of the printed pieces she sees a blurry
face panicked she goes to dex's place to
share her findings in response he shows
her video messages that Josh had sent to
Douglas they also uncover that Josh had
hacked into Douglas's computer system
and unintentionally Unleashed a virus
that opened a portal connecting the
Realms of the living and the dead this
is what happens when you download prawn
from Livewire it is also revealed that
Josh had coded a counter program in
order to solve this and even intended to
meet Douglas at the library but he was
captured by The Entity before doing
anything before long Dax finds Josh's
counter program inside the PC case
cleverly hidden with red tape meanwhile
Isabelle prepares to do her laundry when
suddenly the lights start flickering
soon the washing machine's door
mysteriously opens and the clothes
inside it tumble out as she walks closer
to investigate and quite possibly to get
stuck in there she is horrified by the
appearance of a spider-like creature
that emerges and drains the soul from
her body later that night Maddie returns
home only to find her roommate Isabelle
infected by the evil entity she quickly
tries to call for help but receives no
response from 9-1-1 just then Isabelle
disintegrates into Ash particles after
warning Maddie that the entity will soon
come for her as well frightened and
desperate Maddie contacts Dex who
promptly arrives to pick her up Dex
claims to have discovered Douglas's
location and together they head towards
his place along the way they witnessed
the city in a state of apocalyptic chaos
with wrecked vehicles and Terror
prevailing everywhere they also come
across a family who advises them to seek
refuge in an area with less technology
as the monsters are apparently emerging
from computer systems nevertheless
Maddie and Dex are determined to shut
down the entire system and put an end to
the Mayhem upon reaching Douglas's place
they find his room covered entirely in
red tape moments later Douglas comes out
from a closet and quickly seals the door
with more red tape fearing that the
spirits might enter the duo then demands
to know what's going on and Douglas
reveals how everything began he explains
that Josh and his involvement Telecom
project during which they found
frequencies that no one knew existed
they opened those frequencies and
unintentionally allow the spirits From
Another Dimension to enter the world of
the living in addition Douglas discloses
that these spirits take away one's will
to live forcing people to kill
themselves after learning all of this
Maddie and Dex realized that in order to
put a stop to all of this they must
install Josh's counter program in the
server computer which is located in the
University building's basement with this
information in hand Dex and Maddie make
their way to the server room however
upon arriving at the University they are
threatened by a menacing horde of creepy
cyber entities as they make their way to
the basement through the Halls the
spirits continue to follow them due to
this Dex holds on to the door urging
Maddie to enter the elevator as she
steps in Dex tries to catch up but two
identical Spirits block his path forcing
Maddie to proceed alone descending
towards the basement the power suddenly
goes out causing the elevator to stop
nevertheless Maddie manages to escape
from the stalled elevator and enters the
server room inside she is confronted by
one of the Cyber spirits who approaches
her slowly moments later she finds
herself surrounded by numerous ghostly
arms that seem poised to engulf her it
appears as if she is going to meet her
Doom but right then Dax arrives and
rescues her warning her not to look into
the spirit's face following this Dex
proceeds to the main computer and
installs the counter program this causes
the system to crash Vanishing the
spirits for the time being minutes later
the system reboots automatically and the
spirits reappear forcing Maddie and Dex
to flee the City by car they drive a
considerable distance and then pull over
to rest in the car not long after they
are awakened by a radio broadcast from
the Army announcing the locations of
several safe zones where there are no
internet connections cell phones or
televisions but before they can react to
the news they are attacked by a
four-armed humanoid entity despite this
intense confrontation Dex manages to
start the car and drive to an area with
minimal signal leaving the spirit behind
finally the two make their way to a safe
Zone and the movie ends with Maddie's
voiceover reflecting on their new
reality we can never go back the cities
are theirs our lives are different now
what was meant to connect us to one
another instead connected us to
unimaginable forces the world we once
knew is gone but the will to live Never
Dies not just for us and not for them
this movie won seven Oscars
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching